good morning that gets Tuesday I've
entered it Auto Sava bow after a 30 hour
journey met up with Bridget from the
Gates Foundation and drove into the city
where I got some desperately needed and
delicious Ethiopian coffee shop for a
bit at a local market to get Henri this
Ethiopia soccer jersey and then went to
visit yucca 212 Hospital kinky Theo Pia
is one of the poorest countries in the
world most people live without
electricity or running water most fields
are tilled by animal drawn wooden
ploughs and the shortage of basic
services can be overwhelming for example
the smallest hospital in my hometown of
Indianapolis has eight neonatologist in
Ethiopia a nation of 90 million people
there are seven one of the first was dr.
mulu Elam gasps si so to get to the ektu
12 neonatal intensive care unit you walk
on plywood over standing water that
smells of sewage and then up the stairs
to the NICU dr. Getz si and her nurses
have to be very inventive
for instance they use the oxygen tanks
that you see here combined with tubing
and water to create a kind of CPAP
machine that keeps premature babies
lungs inflated they don't have
respirators or real CPAP machines which
dr. gasps si sites is among her many
critical needs but still she's been very
successful in the past few years her
ward has gone from treating a couple
hundred babies per year to more than
2,000 this little girl had to stay in
the dark while being treated suspected
Venice because the houses puzzle I asked
dr. Cosette say several times about her
choice of specialty continued 24 hours
so why do you choose to do this then
eventually she answered me my phone son
is poised to again hang 20 years ago
more than 15 percent of children who
were born in Ethiopia died before the
age of five today it's less than seven
percent child mortality has fallen
faster in Ethiopia than in the world
overall and it's much lower than it is
in far richer countries how has this
happened well uh nob viously no expert
but one Ethiopia is serious about health
and to organizations like the Gates
Foundation and Save the Children are
helping Ethiopians execute an Ethiopian
health strategy rather than trying to
impose a strategy upon them like take
kangaroo mother care when preterm babies
are well enough they live in the
hospital for weeks or months with their
moms getting constant skin-to-skin
contact the babies and moms are together
in the hospital 24/7 and studies have
shown that this leads to better brain
development lower infection rates and
better weight gain it's cheap it works
and when you make a small investment in
these babies lives now they have a far
better chance of growing up to have
healthy and product
adulthood dr. Kidd says he also told me
stories of failed outreach as when a
dozen seep apps arrived from a charity
all of them adult sized and none of them
of used to her we have to listen to each
other
hey guys found humans to be
extraordinarily generous within their
social networks like think of how
quickly we support friends and
colleagues in need but lack of access to
like Tumblr and YouTube makes most
people living in absolute poverty
totally voiceless in our online world
and inevitably we begin to imagine their
problems as others as things that don't
happen to us if our kids were dying of
malaria and diarrhea if dozens of our
babies were dying for everyone that gets
access to a jerry-rigged CPAP machine we
wouldn't stand for it but the thing is
these are our kids our world is also
very literally their world oh and I did
get to hang out with Bill Gates who is
brilliant and I overcame my tremendous
fear of heights to fly in a helicopter
with him and I will talk about all that
stuff in the coming weeks but for now
let us just pause to be grateful to dr.
this essay who has quietly and
unassumingly saved the lives of
thousands of babies our babies as she
told me I have many children only two
biological but many children Hank I'll
see you on Friday